toyota has given the Yaris a face lift
the front in particular has been
revamped giving the car a more striking
modern appearance the project management
for the new look was headquartered in
France to set itself apart from the
crowd the car maker has given the Yaris
a hybrid drive
and Zach new breeds Toyota's product
manager for the iris as it was offered
as a hybrid for the first time in 2012
back then Toyota anticipated that a
quarter of the irises ordered would be
hybrids but the hybrid success
astonished the company forty percent of
the current generation of the iris is
sold our hybrids the company expects
demand to keep growing to forty-eight
percent in the mid term and in a
long-term more than fifty percent of all
your asses will be delivered as hybrids
ah skinny fat foot so Toyota has set
ambitious goals we wanted to see if the
Yaris hybrid could convince us
automotive bloggers larissa would kofsky
got behind the wheel for us
yes I'm Larissa's first impression of
the irises interior is good there is a
lot of plastic but in this segment in
price class that's inevitable she knows
that one of the materials is unfamiliar
to her it doesn't seem quite modern but
she says even if you don't like it it's
not obtrusive deflation canceled more
down hours of a shot of him full of
machinery phase McNish mark the iris
starts at the push of a button the
battery is charged so we leave the fuel
pump without filling up and off we go
that's fine foods EKGs our car Chester
notes how smoothly and simply the yaris
drives everything works without the
driver having to think too much about it
a plus the car shifts from the electric
to the gasoline engine quickly and
almost unnoticeably another plus the
only hitch is that the engine takes a
moment to respond but Larissa says
that's a very minor problem she's
satisfied with how the car works I
started off kind of fighting fina fish
on the swing at ING support the new
yaris is just under 4 meters long and
1.7 meters wide compact dimensions for
city traffic and parking gonna die de
hoc mundo season pladson money Larissa
says that the car feels roomy enough
even though its dimensions are compact
and practical you have enough space to
feel at ease and free to move she thinks
it's a bit of a shame that the c-pillar
is so large that can be disturbing when
you go into reverse the park or when you
cast a glance over your shoulder to
judge the traffic I in parked but I had
off my angeles on showtime they
construct five ham animals otherwise the
view was good she says and the car ends
almost with the rear windshield so the
c-pillar should make parking a big
problem they can be so Qualls get on
come on
the yaris hybrid we tested has 74
kilowatts of power and consumption is
rated at 3.3 liters per 100 kilometers
it launches from 0 to 100 kilometers an
hour in 11.8 seconds and has a top speed
of 165 kilometres an hour
hinda unstated step behind our cart
sister is a Toyota Yaris hybrid with all
the optional features its price is
twenty one thousand euros Larissa says
she'd consider a lower priced version
with a little less comfort and luxury
but that's a personal decision she
advises anyone who wants to drive a
hybrid car to consider the Toyota Yaris
for my uncle